hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days today's day number 26 and we're
gonna be building something really
exciting but first of all you might
notice that my microphone is in a really
weird position I realized with this road
extendible that you can mount to your
desk it's really versatile it's quite
nice but this whole time I've been
hanging it in front of my face which
means I can't actually see my screen
that well which makes it a little bit
difficult to record coding tutorials so
I maneuvered it in this really unusual
awkward-looking position
and I thought hey I'll give it a try for
this round so here we go over here in my
browser still adjusting this thing not
gonna promise we're keepin - this way
folks all right we have got the day 26
3d layers and what am I talking about
when I say 3d layers well let me show
you here to you right now this might
look like a just like a normal normal
mock-up but the fact is that I created
it in Photoshop using SVG format which
means it's a vector format which means
it's infinitely scalable and super sharp
regardless of your screen size and if
you make it bigger or smaller so I
created this mock-up I included the
Photoshop document in the image folder
as well so maybe you might want to see
and play around with it but this is what
happens when I hover over this mock-up
watch this
that's super cool so you might already
think that's amazing I want to know how
to make that or you might think I have
some ideas and how I want to use that
essentially the reason why we're doing
this is one it's a really big challenge
that we're doing a lot of really
interesting maneuvering using different
different planes the XY & z planes using
transitions transforms and animations
and all that sort of thing so it's a
challenging little task it's a super
impressive way to display almost
anything in a showcase format on your
website so a mock-up a blueprint a
wireframe even images or you know
different elements it's really exciting
now I wouldn't use it as a functional
piece like for navigating or something
like that but to display something in an
impressive manner to show the layers of
your work or something like that this is
the way to do it now let's look at it
one more time I'll show you what's
happening so we have a back layer here
and then we have a middle layer right
here a top layer are these three these
six circles and this text down here this
mock-up text wireframe text just a bunch
of lines that mimics text and then we
have the these two icons here and the
tippy-top i call it and so in one layer
just looking at it straight it looks
like a normal mock-up but when you hover
over it it extends out and shifts it
changes and it's using a 3d
transformation in css3 so why don't we
jump in and get started over here in the
code editor we have the day 26 3d layers
I have all of the assets their index
sandbox final and the image folder which
includes SVG files which are not image
files technically they're actually SVG
files which stands for scalable vector
graphic so it's not an image but you can
add it to your websites and web pages
using the image tag so it it sees it as
an image but the file actually isn't a
technical true image and then I have the
layers that PSD there if you want to
open it up in Photoshop and check it out
play around with it and do whatever so
here's the markup right here in a div
with the class of layers I have four
image tags in there
there they are commented out because you
will see once I uncomment it it creates
a really there's the really large vector
graphics that take up most of the page
you have to scroll down so for
visualization purposes showing you the
demo I didn't want you to see that so
now go ahead and uncomment that and then
you will have your four images scalable
vector graphics now if you check it on
the browser it's gonna look really bad
massive files like this but we're gonna
be using this and manipulating these in
CSS to make them work okay so now that
we've got those SVG images SVG graphics
in there
what we're gonna do is head over to our
sandbox and we're gonna get started with
our coding adventure for this 3d layer
effect let's start off by selecting
layers and then we're going to tell it
position
relative a minimum height of now can be
specific number I'm going to say 640
pixels and that's simply because the
vector graphic here if I were to open it
you can see here the width and the
height are this by default that's really
large so I'm gonna scale that down to
about one third of the size now it's a
rough calculation but I basically took
these and divided them by three and
that's essentially the numbers we're
using I rounded it up a little bit just
so that there were easy numbers to
calculate max width is going to be 360
so now we're gonna have the proper ratio
in this parent layer and now next what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say layers
and then select the image tags we're
gonna say position:absolute because
we're going to be moving them all around
max width it's gonna be 100% so it's
going to it's going to fill out the
content the parent can the parent
container and now we're going to say
height is 100% it's gonna fill out that
parent container
height wise as well length wise vertical
wise whatever transition we're gonna say
all ease 1600 milliseconds and that's
important because we're going to be
doing a transition to give us that
animated effect now we're gonna say
transform style and we're gonna say
preserve 3d because we're gonna have the
transform we're gonna do some
transforming and some shifting and
perspective you know 3d animations and
maneuvering and this preserves the 3d
plane because we wanted to actually look
three-dimensional not like it's skewed
so preserve 3d so we're gonna save that
and now if you checked it out in your
browser you'll see that now we have a
more reasonable size problem here is is
that all the layers are all messed up
and that's because all these SVG
graphics are the same width and same
height and SVG graphics don't really
perform the same way as a PNG bitmap
graphic for example which only takes up
the size of space so for example this as
a PNG would only take up this much of
space but it actually is taking up this
much
space the entire container because of
the height and it's just it's the thing
that you have to work with with SVG
files it's kind of unusual maybe there's
a way around it I'm not entirely
experienced with playing with SPG's but
for this purposes of this tutorial this
is how we're going to do it so now we've
got to maneuver all these things using
positions quite easy but it takes a
little bit of it took me a little bit of
playing around and maneuvering it using
pixels and everything like that but it
finally came to some final numbers so
let's type those in right now
so what we're gonna do I say layers
image of the class of mid because that
we have each of the layers the images
with the class of back mid top and tippy
top so we can do this with them I'm
gonna say the width of the mid layer
which is the not the background layer
but the one just in front of it is 320
pixels and that's because we have a max
width of 360 so that's the background is
360 and we'll this next one to be 320
and then I'm gonna shift it over this
allows me to do some mock margins so to
speak so we're gonna say 320 which will
look something like this you can see now
it's smaller in the background right
here now I'm going to shift it over 20
pixels so that should give us an exact
20 and 20 on either side because its
parent just 360 so 320 plus 40 is 360 so
basic math now we're gonna say layers
image of the class of top and we're
going to give that one a width of 300
pixels so now I'm taking off 20 pixels
in total from that from the top layer
which is this one here as you can see
this one with the logo and then the
navigation so now I want to shift that
in about 30 pixels because it's going to
be 10 pixels on either side as you can
see here that's looking a little bit
better but the top is off I don't like
how the top looks so now I'm going to
say top if I said zero
it would look like this that's because
the top is at zero but I want to move it
up just about five pixels so top
negative five pixels and that looks like
that that looks much better now we have
this tippy top layer which are these
this film reel and the bicycle layers
image and then tippy is what I called it
with 280 pixels so I'm taking off
another 20 pixels
let me say left 40 pixels
and that'll look a little bit better but
now I want to say top and I want to
bring it up negative 150 pixels that
should bring me up to where I want it so
now our mock-up is looking much more
reasonable now what we have to do is
play with it so this is the fun part
so we're going to create a style rule
that says layers upon hover the images
so we're gonna start off with transform
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take hover off for now because I want to
see it while I'm Devin versus having to
hover over every single time to see my
work so I'm just going to say layers
image for now
now this is where all the fun comes in
there's a lot of different values and
functions actually you can add to the
transform property so if I function I
literally mean something like using
rotate X this is a CSS function as a
value for this property so rotate X this
will rotate the image or all the images
on the X plane so I want to rotate it 50
degrees feel free to play around with
this and all the ways that you want but
you can see here now that something
weird has happened it's shifted on an
angle like if you're looking at
something it's shifted like this and so
that's what happened here now it doesn't
look 3d because there is one function
that we have to add but I want to add it
at the end so you can see the dramatic
change so now I want to rotate on the Y
plane 20 degrees let's see what happens
there we go so now we've the Y plane is
this one so the X plane is this one the
Y plane is this one
and now we're going to say rotate on the
z plane negative 25 degrees let's see
what happens okay so now we've shifted
it on this unusual angle as if it's
coming if it's going back this way and
towards us this way so on this like
z-plane I suppose if you play around
with it you'll start to see how it's
moving in digital space now like I said
this doesn't look right it doesn't look
very three-dimensional versus this down
here you can see that looks very
three-dimensional like it's coming off
your screen and towards you well that's
because we need to add an additional
function in here called perspective and
the perspective property or function in
this case creates or enables 3d space on
your screen and produces this illusion
of a distance between the Z plane and
myself the person viewing the screen so
now what's going to happen is if I say
perspective and then let's go 1000
pixels now what's gonna happen here I'll
tell explain how this value the numeric
value works but let's see what it looks
like first so now it looks
three-dimensional it actually has the
proper the proper shape the back looks
smaller than the front it's it looks
like it's coming towards us a little bit
what if I changed just to like 600 now
you can sees way more exaggerated that
the three-dimensional effect so the
smaller this value the more exaggerated
effect because that's that means that
you are closer to this element on the z
plane so you're looking at something
closer as if I were looking at my phone
like this the backside looks smaller
than the front side it's got this
dramatic effect whereas if I was like
this further away versus that so
hopefully that makes sense okay so I'm
gonna go back to I'm gonna say 1200 so
it's it's there it's it's 3d but it's
not crazy exaggerated now as you can see
it's way down here it's not in the right
space it looks kind of sloppy especially
if I hovered it it would fall down the
page would look really weird so we're
gonna remedy that with translate so
we're gonna translate on the x-axis 35
pixels this is simply like doing
positioning but in 3d space so translate
35 pixels that's going to move it to the
left
translate
on the y-axis and we're going to say
zero pixels we don't want it that's up
and down and then translate on the
z-axis and that will bring us back up to
the space where I want it so now we're
looking a lot better so if I were to say
layers hover now layers hover image save
that let's see what that looks like I
hover it shifts and transitions there it
looks pretty good and that's because we
did the transition property up here if I
were to take that out this would be a
lot less nice as you can see it's that
transition that shows us we're going
into three-dimensional space so now what
I want to do is position these in the
proper I want them to expand out I want
it to like give us that well that effect
down here we're at all kind of layers
out that's nice so we want to do that so
we're going to achieve that by
individually styling each image or each
layer so I'm gonna say layers hover
image of the class of mid and I'm gonna
go ahead and copy this entire thing
paste it and change a couple of the
values now I can I probably could take
out the values that I don't need like
maybe if I just took out all of these
and left translate Z translate Zed for
us Canadians and I'm gonna change that
to 240 pixels let's see if just having
one value there works it doesn't the
reason why is because now I'm saying
that transform is not present for all
the other XY and z planes so I have to
leave it in all of these values
translate Z I'm gonna change back to 240
check it out when I hover you see that
layer is now lifted off of the
background copy this now the rest is
super easy paste that whole thing out
image top we're going to change the
value of the last one to 80 so that's
going to be two hundred and eighty
pixels further on the z plane and I'm
going to refresh and hover
now we've got our second layer like that
last but not least copy that paste it
out and now we're gonna do the Tippie
class and that translate Z it's going to
be as you can see in here it's unusual
the way that this floats in space is
because it's a different proportions
than these other elements so we have to
use different values to move it in the
right in the right place so you might
think to 4280 this one's obviously going
to be 320 but that would really mess
things up as you'll see here it's just
really too far and so there's something
about the size of this SVG that just
means we have to change that value so
it's actually 260 and not entirely sure
why if I really looked into it I figure
it out and maybe you have an idea but
this gives us the right effect so now
they're all about the same distance from
each other in that in space in 3d space
and really that is it for our 3d layer
effect now here's a challenge for you
feel free to maneuver this in whatever
way you want the thing is this is a
little bit tricky and finicky if you're
looking for a responsive effect right
now I have hard-coded the width so that
we don't really have any issues but even
in the background here the background is
at 100% you can see things are looking a
little bit different here the other
thing is when you hover over this layer
these layers come out and then hover
again at any point in that transition it
does like a weird as you could see like
it kind of starts the animation from
where you clicked on it or where you
hovered so it really messes with it and
it's really unusual so you'd have to do
this in the right controlled space and
really play around with it to make sure
you're doing the right thing so you
don't have a really wonky looking
animation this is really for demo
purposes to show you what you can do
with 3d space rotates translates
transforms and everything like that I
hope today's lesson was valuable
educational and fun for you thanks for
hanging out for day 26
closing in on the last few days here and
I'll see you in day number 27
[Music]